THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
THE LIBERAL MEDIA IS ONCE AGAIN
WHIPPING ITSELF INTO A FRENZY
OVER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FIRST UP, AMID THE PRESIDENTS
BRING BATTLE WITH STORMY DANIELS
AND HER LAWYER, MICHAEL
AVENATTI, TRUMP-HATING MSNBC
HOST MIKA BRZEZINSKI CALLING ON
THE PRESIDENT TO BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY, MANY
WAYS THIS PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN US
THAT HE'S NOT FIT, POSSIBLY NOT
EVEN WELL.
YOU ARE WORKING FOR A PRESIDENT
WHO IS NOT FIT TO LEAD WHO IS
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN 5
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN M
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN N
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN T
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN ,
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN O
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN E
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN H
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN U
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN ,
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN T
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN N
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN G
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN T
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN O
GOING TO DO SOMETHING CRAZY IN R
TOMORROW.
WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED TO HEAR
FROM HIM TO START THINKING 25TH
AMENDMENT OR SOMETHING ELSE?
>> Jesse: CNN'S DON LEMON
PILING ON WITH HIS USUAL
PERSONAL ATTACKS.
>> DOES HE OWN A MIRROR?
HE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
GAINING WEIGHT.
HOW PEOPLE LOOK.
THIS HE OWN A MIRROR THAT
DOESN'T HAVE VASELINE OVER IT OR
A CLOTH?
ALL HE HAS TO DO IS LOOK IN THE
MIRROR.
DONALD TRUMP IS NO PRIZE, AND IF
I WERE HIM, NOT THAT I'M ONE
EITHER, I WOULD KEEP MY THOUGHTS
ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE'S LOOKS TO
MYSELF.
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT ALL.
SOME.
SOME IN THE MEDIA TRYING TO SPIN
ELIZABETH WARREN'S DISASTROUS
DNA REVEAL BY USING IT TO
PROTECT TRUMP.
>> IT'S REALLY NOT ABOUT THE
VERACITY OF HER STATEMENT.
IT'S ULTIMATELY A DOG WHISTLE
THAT PLAYS INTO THE GRIEVANCES
OF HIS BASE, HIS OVERWHELMINGLY
WHITE BASS, AND IT GOES INTO
MULTIPLE THEMES THAT ARE AT
ISSUE FOR CONSERVATIVES,
PREDOMINATELY AROUND AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
PEOPLE SORT OF CHEATING THE
SYSTEM BY CLAIMING TO BE
MINORITIES.
>> Jesse: THE ARCHITECT OF THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL, FORMER OBAMA
ADVISOR BEN RHODES, THIS TALKING
POINT ABOUT THE DISAPPEARANCE OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" COLUMNIST.
>> THE SAUDIS WANT TO SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT YOU ARE NOT SAFE
ANYWHERE IF YOU CRITICIZE US.
THE MESSAGE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
SENDING US THAT THERE'S NO
CONSEQUENCES.
VALUES LIKE FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AND DISSENT, SUDDENLY THEY ARE
VERY ENDANGERED AROUND THE
WORLD.
THAT'S A LINE I THINK IT'S
GETTING WORSE.
>> Jesse: LET'S PICK UP ON
WHAT BEN RHODES SAID.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY
IRRESPONSIBLE TO LINK
"THE WASHINGTON POST" COLUMNIST
DEATH WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WAR
ON THE MEDIA.
THAT'S JUST RHETORIC.
JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN DYING IN
MEXICO FOR DECADES, BEFORE
DONALD TRUMP STARTED SAYING
THINGS LIKE THIS.
DO YOU THINK HE'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR "THE WASHINGTON POST"
BLOGGER'S DEMISE?
>> Juan: NO.
>> Jesse: WHY WOULD HE SAY
THAT?
>> Juan: YOU HAVE PRESS UNDER
FIRE IN SO MANY AREAS OF THE
WORLD.
YOU CITED MEXICO.
I'VE BEEN TO MEXICO AS A GUEST
OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT TALK
ABOUT THREATS AGAIN JOURNALISTS.
YOU SEE IT IN TURKEY.
YOU SEE IT THROUGHOUT MUCH OF
THE WORLD.
WE KNOW ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
ATTITUDE BUT WHEN THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WHO SHOULD
BE STANDING UP FOR DEMOCRATIC
VALUES, PRESS FREEDOM, FREEDOM
OF DISSENT, SAYS THAT THE PRESS
IN HIS COUNTRY IS THE ENEMY OF
THE PEOPLE, PERPETRATING FAKE
NEWS, I THINK IT DOES EMPOWER
THE AUTOCRATS ELSEWHERE TO SAY
WELL, IT'S JUST LIKE THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE JUST GOING AFTER THEM THE
WAY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES GOES AFTER IT.
IT'S NOT HEALTHY.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE WAY TO LINK IT.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN DRAW THAT
KIND OF CONNECTION.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE IT'S
EMPOWERED ANYBODY.
THE PRESIDENT LOVES THE PRESS,
MORGAN.
HE COURTS THEM FANATICALLY.
HE JUST DID AN INTERVIEW WITH
BLOOMBERG, AP, FOX NEWS, AND
6060 MINUTES WITHIN A WEEK.
HE'S FEEDING THEM ALL THE TIME.
HE LOVES THE PRESS.
>> Morgan: WHEN THE PRESIDENT
FIRST CAME OUT, WHEN THIS STORY
FIRST CAME OUT ABOUT KHASHOGGI,
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THE
PRESIDENT SAID WAS HOW HE
MENTIONED THAT IT WAS UPSETTING
THAT HE WAS A JOURNALIST AND
THAT THIS HAPPENED TO HIM.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
GOING ON HERE IN THIS SPECIFIC
CASE IS THERE'S A LOT GOING ON
BEHIND THE SCENES.
THE COUNTRY TEAM IN THESE
EMBASSIES AND CONSULATES, THEY
ARE WORKING TOGETHER.
WE HAVE LEGAL ATTACHES AND ALL
THESE CONSULATES AND EMBASSIES
WORKING WITH OTHER AGENCIES
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING
TO GIVE SPACE TO OUR GOVERNMENT
AND THE TURKISH AND SAUDI
GOVERNMENTS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
ACTUALLY GOES ON AND HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Jesse: WE HEARD ALL OF THE
SOUND AT THE TOP.
IT'S ALL SPIN.
SPIN ON THE MIDDLE EAST, SPIN ON
ELIZABETH WARREN.
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE SPIN FROM
MIKA BRZEZINSKI.
DO THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ANY PLANS
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S HURTING THEM, 19 DAYS
UNTIL THE MIDTERMS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CONSUMING ALL
THE OXYGEN IN THE MEDIA.
BASICALLY WHAT HE'S DECIDED HE'S
GOING TO FLOOD THE ZONE AND
NOBODY ELSE CAN GET ON
TELEVISION UNLESS THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT HIM AND TALKING
ABOUT HIM IN SOME WAY THAT WOULD
BE DEROGATORY BECAUSE THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY GET THEM HEADLINES.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
HE HAS SAID IN ONE OF THOSE
INTERVIEWS HE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY THINK THE MIDTERMS
ARE A REFERENDUM ON HIM.
HE HAS SET OTHERWISE IN THE
PAST.
HE SAYS HE WELCOMES IT BEING
ABOUT HIM BUT HIS ACTIONS SHOW
DIFFERENTLY.
HE KNOWS IF HE'S OUT THERE AND
HE'S DRIVING NEWS MEDIA AND HIS
VOTERS GET ENGAGED, THAT'S --
THAT MAKES RED STATE DEMOCRATS
VERY NERVOUS.
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO BE THE
MAJORITY OF TRUMP VOTERS COMING
OUT THOSE RED STATES, THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS UP FOR REELECTION WILL
LOSE.
>> Juan: YOUR POINT IS WHEN HE
SAYS HORSE FACE, HE IS EXCITING
HIS BASE?
>> Dana: NO, I DIDN'T SAY
THAT.
HE'S DOING ALL SORTS OF MEDIA.
HE SAID SO MANY THINGS ON SO
MANY DIFFERENT TOPICS.
HE SAID THE FED IS THE BIGGEST
THREAT.
THERE'S A MILLION THREADS.
YOU COULD PULL ANY OF THEM.
MY POINT IS HE IS CONSUMING ALL
THE OXYGEN AND THAT BY TOMORROW
MORNING, THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
OUTRAGE THAT THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT.
>> Juan: I THINK IS BAD TIMING
FOR REPUBLICANS TO SUDDENLY BE
INSULTING --
AMERICAN WOMEN.
>> Dana: IT MIGHT BE BAD FOR
HIM IN-HOUSE SUBURBAN DISTRICTS.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY BAD FOR HIM
TO BE ON THE NEWS ALL THE TIME
IF YOU'RE A RED STATE REPUBLICAN
TRYING TO UNSEAT A DEMOCRAT.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK ANY
DEMOCRAT CAN CRITICIZE ANYONE
ABOUT BAD TIMING, AFTER THE
LIVES WARREN THING.
YOU BROUGHT UP MIKA, BEN RHODES,
DON LEMON.
MORNING JOE REMINDS ME OF A
POLITICAL TALK SHOW THAT YOU SEE
WITHIN A TV SHOW, LIKE "HOUSE OF
CARDS.
IT'S ENTIRELY FABRICATED AND
PHONY.
IT HAS THE SAME FACES DURING THE
SAME THING.
ALMOST LIKE IT IS SCRIPTED FOR
ANOTHER SHOW.
MIKA, GOD LOVE HER, BUT SHE IS
THE DEFINITION OF STUPIDITY.
SHE IS ETERNALLY SHOCKED BY
SOMETHING THAT THE REST OF
AMERICA IS USED TOO.
FOR EXAMPLE, IT'S LIKE GOING TO
GET INDIAN FOOD AND COMPLAINING
THAT IT'S SPICY.
IT WOULD BE LIKE GOING TO SEE A
QUINTON TARANTINO FILM AND WHEN
YOU LEAVE, GO, MY GOD, THAT WAS
VIOLENT.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
>> Jesse: SHE KNOWS SO BETTER
THAN ANYBODY.
>> Greg: THE IRONY AND SHE
HELPED GET HIM ELECTED.
SHE GIVE HIM MORE OXYGEN THAN
ANYBODY.
THERE IS A PROFESSOR WHO BROUGHT
UP A REALLY GOOD WAY TO DESCRIBE
IT, THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
MEDIA AND THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED
FOR TRUMP.
THE MEDIA EXCESSES OVER THE
PERIPHERAL, THAT MEANS WORDS,
MANNER, STYLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT VOTED FOR TRUMP
CAN TOLERATE ALL THAT BECAUSE
THEY FOCUS ON THE SUBSTANCE
WHICH IS JOBS, ECONOMY, PEACE IN
THE KOREAS, THE SUPREME COURT,
WORLD'S MOST COMPETITIVE
ECONOMY.
BEAT OUT SINGAPORE.
YOU HAVE BEN RHODES.
>> Jesse: TAKE THAT,
SINGAPORE.
>> Greg: ALL ROADS LEAD TO
FAILURE.
HE HAS NO RIGHT TO TALK ABOUT
SECURITY.
HIS NAIVE ARROGANCE GAVE US
TRUMP BECAUSE THEY CREATED A
FOREIGN POLICY THAT SENT OUR
LEADERS AROUND SAYING WE ARE
SORRY AND THEN WE HAVE A LEADER
THAT GETS ELECTED THAT SAYS NO,
WE ARE NOT.
THERE IS DIRECT LINKAGE.
LASTLY, LEMON HAS NO RIGHT TO
TALK ABOUT ANYTHING GIVEN THE
FACT THAT HE BASICALLY SNICKERED
THROUGHOUT THE SEGMENT MOCKING
KANYE'S MENTAL HEALTH AND
CALLING HIM A BUNCH OF
DISGUSTING NAMES.
HE SAID TRUMP COULD USE A
MIRROR.
I'M SURE LEMON MUST HAVE 100 OF
THEM AT HOME.
>> Jesse: TV IS A PRETTY
AESTHETICALLY ORIENTED INDUSTRY.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY ON TV CAN
TALK ABOUT LOOKS.
>> Greg: I CAN.
>> Jesse: GREG, YOU ARE THE
MOST HANDSOME MAN ON FOX NEWS.
>> Juan: GREG, DON'T YOU THINK
THESE COMMENTS ARE ADOLESCENT?
YOU SAY TRUMP SUPPORTERS
DISMISSED -- NOT A BIG DEAL BUT
I THINK THE FACT THAT HE KEEPS
GOING AFTER AMERICAN WOMEN IN
TERMS OF THEIR LOOKS.
AT SOME POINT --
>> Greg: YOU ARE WRONG.
HE GOES AFTER EVERYONE.
HE GOES AFTER MEN, WOMEN.
I AM SURE HE IS GONE AFTER
CHILDREN AS WELL.
ANIMALS.
TED CRUZ.
>> Jesse: REMEMBER ROMNEY
WALKS LIKE A PENGUIN?
>> Greg: HE WASN'T FAR OFF ON
THAT.
>> Juan: WHEN I WAS SAYING
IT'S ABOUT WOMEN'S LOOKS.
>> Greg: HE WILL MAKE FUN OF
EVERYTHING.
HE DOESN'T CENSOR.
>> Jesse: I THINK WOMEN ARE
VERY UPTIGHT ABOUT THEIR LOOKS
AND IF I SAY --
>> Dana: WEIGHT.
>> Jesse: I AM UPTIGHT ABOUT
MY LOOKS.
>> Greg: HOW DOES THAT MAKE
YOU FEEL, DANA?
ARE YOU UPTIGHT ABOUT YOUR
LOOKS, MORGAN?
THAT'S THE ASSUMPTION.
>> Morgan: I THINK EVERYONE
WAS ON TELEVISION --
STARING IN THE MIRROR.
>> Greg: HOW CAN I NOT STARE